It's finally here off several failures
and a few scandals.
2017 closed with Donald Trump hands,
the republican party's first major
political victory since the presidential
elections that landed the well known
casino and property developments magnate
in the Oval Office.
Oh,
of course.
Talking about the tax reform that after
being approved by Congress was signed by
President Trump on December the 22nd
three point $2 trillion in tax cuts for
American families,
including the doubling of the standard
deduction and the doubling of the child
tax credit.
This is,
as I'm sure you've heard,
the largest tax reform in 30 years.
The impacts and the controls have been
massive,
and that's appropriate for the
importance of this political
events.
Print supporters.
The tax reform is a real revolution,
as many qualifiers as the biggest tax
reduction in the history of the United
States.
This is good for American business.
It's good for the American economy,
and it's good for the American people
for its detractors.
However,
the reform is poorly developed and lies
far from the promises that the president
made during his electoral campaign
tax.
The florists.
People.
Okay.
All right.
Other 35,000 book will be taxed the most
under 75,000 will be the second highest
tech and the billionaires and the
millionaires get a tax guy.
What's wrong with this picture?
So I think the questions to be asked
here are very clear.
We have to ask what's true in all of
this,
what's it really all about and is it as
large as people are saying?
And ultimately what can everyone expect
from this?
Well,
let's have a look.
Okay.
In this video where they explored the
positive and also the not so positive
aspects of a reform that is its first
consequence as managed to calm the
waters in the Republican party in a way,
reconcile Donald Trump with the party
leaders of both chambers of Congress and
given how things were going after a year
of taunts attacks and mistrust,
this is really worth acknowledging.
Check out what the media says.
Just a few short months ago,
president had been a very focused,
of course on a well his twitter account.
He fired off another twitter storm
yesterday about his frustrations with
party leaders,
Mitch Mcconnell and Paul Ryan.
I with all the invitee?
No,
in the GOP.
Do Democrats have a political advantage
now?
Well,
before we go on,
what can we expect?
Let's see what this law at tax reduction
within the United States really means.
Well,
the first question we need to answer is
how much does it really actually reduce
taxes?
Is this really the biggest tax drop in
US history?
Now,
Donald Trump certainly has his steak
today.
It was my great honor to sign the
largest tax cuts and reform in the
history of our country.
So according to the president and also
many Republican Party politicians,
Americans are facing a great fiscal
revolution.
A revolution that could make even Ronald
Reagan's cuts look pretty tiny
is this is the biggest tax cuts and
reform in the history of our country.
This is bigger than actually president
Reagan's.
How
ever dear viewer,
before you launch your celebration,
please do wait a minute because we
already know that donald isn't
particularly fond of the truth and well,
you know what?
While this time it's really not any
different.
Yes,
sadly that is right.
This fiscal reform isn't the largest in
US history.
Indeed not at all.
In fact,
it's not even among the top five.
Allow me to explain,
even though we can say that Americans
are facing the biggest tax system reform
in 30 years,
because this law does change a lot of
things.
The truth is that when it comes to
lowering taxes,
it's really not that impressive.
The general estimates is that this
reform,
we'll lower taxes between 0.7 and 0.9%
of the GDP over the next 10 years.
That is approximately one point $5
trillion.
Well,
the fact is,
according to the committee for a
responsible federal budget and
independent think tank and also
according to the u s treasury,
this is actually the eighth largest tax
reduction since 1918 indeed it is three
times smaller than Reagan.
Yes,
indeed.
The problem here,
it may actually be the Donald Trump is
simply allergic to the trees,
but anyway.
Nice.
What are the main points of this tax
reduction and what are its benefits?
Well.
Let's dive into those right now the
reforms highlights,
even though there are a lot of changes,
there are really only two main points to
consider here.
One is lowering income tax.
That is to see the tax that affects
natural persons,
just regular man on the streets and the
other is the changes to corporate tax
first case,
but natural persons.
This reduction is really,
really small.
C,
80% of taxpayers will see an income tax
change of less than 2% and most won't
even really notice it.
And regarding this matter,
trump has blatantly broken his word.
So
why is this?
Well,
because Donald Trump promised a new tax
system a much simpler one with only
three or four brackets and much lower,
right?
Yeah,
we're going to cut the individual rate
from seven brackets
to form.
In the end,
things have virtually remained the same
with seven brackets kind of rates
slightly lower than before.
And that's not all this reduction.
It's also temporary.
Yeah,
that's right.
This is going to disappear in 2025
unless Congress changes what it is
approved.
By the way.
One very interesting thing about this
law is that it limits deductions for
state and local taxes.
That is,
it punishes states with higher taxes and
encourages them to lower them.
Now on the other hands,
we have the reduction of corporate
income tax,
which is so to speak,
the jewel,
the reform,
yeah.
The tax decreases from 35% to 21% and it
changes its scoped so that it ceases to
be global and to facts almost
exclusively.
The United States allow me to explain
myself because this is really important
to up until now,
when American multinationals such as
apple or Google,
made money abroad as for example they do
in Ireland,
despite having already paid taxes to the
Irish governments,
they had to pay again in the u s for
what they had earned in islands.
If they wanted to bring the money into
the United States.
Essentially they were paying twice for
any money they were bringing home.
Now,
of course,
these companies weren't really very
willing to do that,
so you could probably guess what
happened next.
Well these companies,
they simply didn't repatriate their
income to the United States as the
cancer didn't.
Financial centers like Luxembourg,
Ireland or Singapore and the figures,
they're pretty dizzying.
We're talking about more than two point
$5 trillion here.
Well,
the fact is that from now on,
thanks to this reform,
US multinationals will only pay the u s
treasury for income they make within the
country and for the money that's already
outside the new law states that they can
bring it home as a very attractive
conditions.
As an example,
I have millions of dollars overseas.
I can't bring it back into this gun.
So indeed,
it's highly likely that this year we're
going to begin to see it.
Large amounts of money moving towards
the United States
away.
As a side note,
evenly,
the corporate income tax decreased from
35% 21% that isn't actually that big of
a drop.
On the one hand,
while the tax rates do decrease,
some deductions eliminated or limited,
and those deductions previously allowed
companies to pay an average of 20%
before the reform.
On the other hand though,
the old US income tax was the highest in
the OEC.
D If we take into account all the taxes
companies pays not only on income.
The truth is that although the United
States pays a lot of taxes,
Europe's are usually even higher.
For example,
the ones in Spain,
France or even Janet.
I would even say even if it isn't as
impressive as the republican state,
it will have positive consequences for
the u s economy from now on the country.
It will be more attractive to investors.
It's companies will earn more money and
a lot of income that was previously
retained,
a broad,
we'll begin to move to the United
States,
so do you use all of this and due to
some other smaller changes,
just this once and certainly without
setting a precedence here at visual
politic we can say trump seems to be
doing well in terms of tactics.
Awesome.
If you think that's it,
you are very,
very wrong.
The reform also certainly has its
negative points.
The shadows,
those
who followed this channel?
No,
that we usually say that things aren't
as pretty as they seem.
Well that is precisely the case with
this tax reform law.
On the one hand,
the positive effects of this log will
most likely be much more limited than
the Republican party claims.
And why is this?
Well,
allow me to
you.
It's economy is growing at a good pace.
That is almost full employment and
corporate profits are historically high.
That is to say right now American
companies which are already very
competitive,
mostly need fewer regulations,
the ability to trade freely and the
freedom to hire the workers they need,
including the best talents they can get
from abroad.
Yeah.
MMM.
As you probably know,
trump doesn't exactly play that way.
So yeah,
the reform will have positive effects,
but not as many as some people do.
Think while it is not the largest tax
cut ever,
it is the most poorly timed tax cut in
history.
The economy is near full employment and
the national debt is it postwar record
and rising fast.
Leonard Eberman Tax Policy Center,
cofounder and institute fellow at the
Urban Institute.
On the other hand,
this government isn't talking about
reducing public spending.
Indeed,
on the contrary,
they want to increase public spending on
infrastructure and the military,
and of course with fewer taxes.
This means more deficits and more public
debt as well.
If we're honest,
the U S has quite a track record of
that.
And lastly,
develop deep forgotten party in this
reform is of course,
the middle class.
That's right.
The ones who will benefit the most from
this reform will be the wealthiest
classes,
including,
of course,
Donald Trump himself
in the center of the stage tonight.
There's this man Donald Trump.
Am I allowed to accept it?
Had Rich Friends of mine come up to me
and say,
Donald,
you're doing this tax plan.
We don't want anything.
We don't
president.
Consider that he and his companies would
benefit so well from this reform.
Well,
I'm going to leave that for you too.
Sit Up.
The Republican Party
has betrayed working families.
This tax scam takes billions of dollars
away from the middleclass,
enhance it over to Republican donors and
wealthy corporations while mortgaging
away the future of our economy by adding
one point $5 trillion in debt.
Tom Perez,
chairman of the Democratic National
Committee.
Maybe this is why Paul stayed,
that most Americans do not really like
this change.
The general perception that seems to be
that this reform,
it was made by and forth the richest.
In fact,
unlike what we might expect,
many Democratic Party leaders are
rubbing their hands together and
thinking that this may favor them in the
mid term elections,
which will be held in November.
Only time it's going to tell.
But what we think is that this reform
will make us companies more attractive
and that's in principle is a very good
thing.
Of course,
as things are,
the US needs many more measures which
trump has ruled out.
But on the other hand,
there may be time for the United States
to begin taking their public debts
terrifying growth much more seriously.
And by the way,
just as a final note yet,
with this reform,
we all kind of win in away.
You see,
if the United States reduces its taxes,
it's also been shown historically that
other governments will be unwilling to
raise.
That's,
but for now,
it's your turn.
Are you in favor of this tax reform?
Well,
please let us know in the comments below
as well as in guest survey.
And as always,
I really hope you enjoy this video.
If you did,
please do hit that like button and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel brand
new videos every Monday and Thursday.
Also,
please don't forget to check it off.
Friends at the reconsider media
podcasts,
they provided the vocals in this
episode,
but we're not mine.
And as always,
thank you for watching.
As an example,
I have millions of dollars overseas.
I can't bring it back into this skunk.
Am I allowed to accept tips?
I've had rich friends of mine come up to
me and say,
Donald,
you're doing this tax plan.
We don't want anything.
We don't.